Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen auf die europäischen Top-Ligen zurückblicken, nachdem wir ja schon in dieser Saison besser drauf geguckt haben denn je. Deswegen begrüße ich euch zur Rasenfunk Ligatour. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Wir wollen heute noch ein letztes Mal für diese Saison 21, 22 auf die Serie A, La Liga, die Premier League und auch die Liga blicken. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich jetzt erst mal drei Gäste hier begrüßen darf. Zum einen Joachim Hebel von Sky und der Saunen. Servus Jogi. Ja, schön, dass wir wieder in dieser Runde zusammen sind. Ebenfalls hier ist Marius Soyke, den kennt ihr natürlich von Serie Amore und transfermark.de. Hallo Marius.
Schön, dass ich immer wieder dabei sein kann. Danke für die Einladung.
Ich würde gerne mal einen Anzug in deinem Auftrag kaufen. Aber das ist vielleicht eine andere.
Wir gehen mal zusammen shoppen. Das will ich sehen.
Das würden doch so meine andere gerne sehen. Ich bin nicht so... Ich bin nicht so der Shopping-Dub. Du kannst für mich shoppen gehen. Okay, das waren die Enttäuschungen. Marius, ich würde dich gerne als erstes fragen, nach den Spielerneuentdeckungen dieser Saison. Wer sind Spieler, die diese abgelaufenen Serie A Saison ihren Stempel aufdrücken konnten? Und wo man es vorher vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte?
Da muss ich direkt auch wieder zum Meister zu Milan springen. Denn wenn man eine sehr junge Mannschaft hat und am Ende die Meisterschaft gewinnt, dann ist es logisch, dass da auch welche, den direkten Durchbruch in dieser Saison geschafft haben. Und das ist einmal allen voran. Pierre Caloulou, ein Innenverteidiger, der vor anderthalb oder zwei Jahren aus Lyon gekommen ist, da noch kein einziges Profi-Spiel gemacht hat. Und so ein bisschen eigentlich als Backup für die rechtsverteidigende Position, als Talent. Den bauen wir vielleicht mal so langsam und behutsam aufgeholt wurde. Und der dieses Jahr so im Spätherbst rum plötzlich in die erste Mannschaft reingeworfen werden musste, weil sich mit Simon Kehr, der der große alte weise Mann quasi in der Innenverteidigung bei Milan einen Kreuzbandriss zugezogen hat und der Kapitän Romagnoli auch verletzt war. Und ja, dann gab es quasi keinen anderen mehr. Und dann ist eben Carlou Loup da reingezogen worden und hat an der Seite von Fikaio Tomori eine unfassbare Entwicklung hingenommen, also hingelegt. Habe ich in der Serie A von einem Verteidiger in den jungen Jahren, weiß ich nicht mehr, wann ich das das letzte Mal gesehen habe, also nächstes Jahr hoffentlich dann auch als Stammkraft in der Champions League, kann man sich dann auch nicht Serie A-Fans davon überzeugen. Ist ein weiteres unglaublich großes französisches Talent und hat also, ja, meinen Mind geblut.
Aber er wird in die Premier League wechseln, habe ich das jetzt gerade richtig rausgehört?
Nein, Champions League habe ich Premier League gesagt. Ich hoffe, er wechselt noch nicht in die Premier League. Aber wegen Geldern und so kann das natürlich in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann mal der Fall sein.
Ja, ja, gut, das kann passieren. Aber es ist gut, also Champions League war gemeint. Wen gibt es denn darüber hinaus noch?
Mein MVP der Saison ist eigentlich Raphael Leao, also auch ein Milan-Spieler. Der ist natürlich vorher schon bekannt gewesen, hat aber in dieser Saison den Sprung zum wirklich alles entscheidenden Offensivspieler bei Milan gemacht, auch jetzt gerade in der Saison-Schlussphase eigentlich an allen Toren mehr oder weniger direkt beteiligt gewesen. Und es würde mich nicht überraschen, wenn man ihn zum Spieler der Saison wählt. Und abgesehen davon gibt es noch so ein paar andere Talente. Bei Udinese gibt es ein Destiny-Odojie und Jean-Victor Mackengo. Das sind zwei Mittelfeld- bzw. Außenspieler, die auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Jahren den Schritt zu Top-Vereinen machen werden. Bei Atalanta tatsächlich auch. Die Verletzungsprobleme hatte ich angesprochen. Da hat sich Giorgio Scalvini hervorgetan, ein ganz junger Innenverteidiger, italienischer Unnationalspieler. Dem könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass er nächstes Jahr direkt mit Anfang 20 zum Stammpersonal gehören wird. Ich habe sie als positive Überraschung extra nicht vergessen, sondern wollte das –wir kommen ja auch noch auf Anekdoten zu sprechen –da wollte ich dann was zu Ues Salenitana sagen. Aber da muss man auch eine Spielerentdeckung auf jeden Fall erwähnen. Das ist Ederson, ein brasilianischer Mittelfeldspieler, den sie erst im Winter verpflichtet haben und der wirklich maßgeblichen Anteil daran hatte, dass dieser Verein aus einer absolut aussichtslosen Situation noch den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat.
Sehr schön. Salenitana hatte ich mir nämlich noch aufgeschrieben, dass ich danach noch frage. Alex, wer hat in La Liga zur Überraschung aller überzeugt? Da muss man –man kommt nicht drum herum –man muss einfach Gavi nennen, den 17-jährigen Shootingstar des FC Barcelona. Und den erwähne ich jetzt nicht, weil ich dem FC Barcelona recht nahe stehe, sondern wer mit 17 aus der Jugend direkt in die 1. Mannschaft kommt. Also er hat die 2. Mannschaft, Barca B, die in der 3. Liga spielt, übersprungen. Normalerweise ist ja der Weg so, dass du aus der B-Jugend, A-Jugend dann in die 2. Mannschaft kommst, da in der 3. Liga spielst. Und dann, wenn du das Talent hast, hochgezogen wird. Nee, er hat die Barca B, die 2. Mannschaft übersprungen, kam direkt zu den Profis und jetzt kommt es. Wettbewerbsübergreifend, 47 Einsätze. Nur 2 Barca-Spieler haben, also 47, die Zahl an sich ist ja eh verrückt, aber nur 2 Spieler haben mehr. Sergio Busquets, 51 Spiele. Marc-Andrej Ter Stegen, der Stammtorhüter, die Nummer 1, 49 Spiele. Dann kommt schon der 17-jährige Gavi. Also das ist absolut unbegreiflich, um ehrlich zu sein, wie so jemand nicht nur ab und zu Einsätze bekommt. So wie beispielsweise Jamal Musiale bei den Bayern. Wird mal hier eingewechselt, mal da. Dann gelingt ihm natürlich tolle Sachen. Nee, der wurde direkt Stammspieler und hat die drittmeisten Spiele in der Saison absolviert für Barca. Also ein absoluter Eckpfeiler. Und vor allem nicht nur als Joker, sondern in La Liga hat er 28-mal in der Startelf gestanden. Das ist einfach, das ist richtig krass. Am Ende, ich glaube, 2 Tore, 6 Assists. Also die Zahlen sind jetzt auch nicht so schlecht. Wohlgemerkt als 17-Jähriger, der nicht mal 3. Liga gespielt hat. Davor wirklich nur in der Jugend. Deswegen ist das die Spielerneuentdeckung wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Nummer 1 sind die anderen Spieler, die ich jetzt so in der Folge wahrscheinlich nennen will, oder muss, weil du ja mehrere Spieler nennst, die sind ja nicht neu in dem Sinne, sondern die waren ja alle schon entweder in La Liga im Einsatz oder in anderen Ligen. Und wer kommt da noch so? Also für mich so ein kleiner Shootingstar der Saison oder so der, ja, most improved player, um da in dem NBA-Rhythmus zu bleiben, Vinicius Junior bei Real Madrid, eine enorme Entwicklung vorgenommen. Ist jetzt natürlich europäisch gesehen oder generell kein unbekannter, klar. Hat aber wirklich einen tollen Schwung gemacht. Am Ende 17 Tore und 10 Assists in La Liga geschossen, hätte ich ihm so niemals zugetraut, weil er als absoluter Chancentod eigentlich bekannt war. Also wirklich, der vor dem Tor, so blöd das klingt, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen nach Doppelpass, aber der kein Scheuntor trifft vor der Kiste normalerweise, dass er jetzt nicht nur zweistellig trifft, ist schon klasse, und ich hätte ihm so nicht zugetraut. Wirklich 17 Tore, 10 Assists, auch enorm wichtige Tore geschossen, Traumtore geschossen. Also unter Ancelotti da wirklich eine enorme Entwicklung vorgenommen, einen tollen Leistungssprung und so ein bisschen der Shooting-Star. Denn der andere ist ja logisch, also Karin Benzema über den brauchen wir wirklich nicht sprechen. Nee, und den lass ich auch als Neuentdeckung nicht mehr durchgehen. Den kannst du nicht durchgehen lassen, nee. Einfallen würde man natürlich, Usman Dembelé, passt natürlich auch nicht zum Thema Neuentdeckung, aber man muss ganz kurz erwähnen, dass er die meisten Assists in La Liga hinbekommen hat. 13 Assists in, Achtung, 21 Ligaspielen nur. Wie viele davon aus dem Krankenhaus heraus? Das ist es ja, er ist ja ab und zu mal verletzt in 21 Spielen 13 Assists. Ich bin jetzt in Mathe nicht so bewandert, aber wenn man das mal auf 38 Spiele hochrechnen würde, oder lasst es 35 sein, das wäre ein ziemlich guter Wert. Also es ist ja so schon, er ist ja der Beste in der Saison. Aber Tor kann er immer noch nicht schießen, ich glaube, ein mickriges Saison-Törchen. Aber 13 Assists auch nicht so schlecht. Also auch ein Player to watch ohne Assist ablösefrei. Von daher, ja, anderes Thema. Von daher nur 300 Millionen Handgeld. Gut, das waren die Spielerneuentdeckungen. Alex, du... Ach nee, Entschuldigung. Jogi muss natürlich noch. Sorry, Jogi. Jetzt fängt es schon an. Da lässt meine Kondition nach am Ende der Saison. So ehrlich müssen wir sein. Wen gibt es denn in der Premier League noch zu nennen?
Ja, es gibt mit Sicherheit so Spieler, die natürlich den nächsten Schritt gemacht haben, so in die Weltspitze, wo ich jetzt echt interessiert bin dran. Was machen die? Zum Beispiel so ein Declan Rice bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt, der auch schon angekündigt hat, dass er den Club verlassen möchte. Dass einer, der noch mal einen Schritt gemacht hat, noch mal ein bisschen erwachsener geworden ist, auch noch mal dem Mann immer nachgesagt, da kann ich mit dem Ball so umgehen. Das ist jetzt der Spieler, der Mittelfeldspieler, der die meisten Dribblings in den Raum rein hat, also in nach vorne. Also jemand, der wirklich noch mal technisch viel besser geworden ist, die Passquote erhöht hat. Da bin ich richtig gespannt, ob für den jemand richtig Geld hinlegen wird, weil dann wären es wirklich so über 100. Da bin ich echt mal gespannt, da hat David Moyes gesagt, es gibt Spieler, die sind über 100 Millionen Euro gewechselt, die können Decker und Rice nicht mal die Schuhe binden. Dann sind wir mal gespannt, für wie viel der weggeht. Das ist sicherlich eine sehr interessante Geschichte. Aber dann gibt es natürlich Typen wie Gerald Bone zum Beispiel, bei dem viele gesagt haben, das wäre der most improved player, der in dieser Saison 12 Tore, 10 Assists gemacht hat. Der hat am Schluss jetzt noch mal so eine kleine Phase gehabt, wo es schwächer war, dann wurde es wieder besser. Aber der hat einen Zeitgang mal wirklich so ausgesehen, als wäre er der nächste, den vielleicht Liverpool mal holen möchte oder so etwas in Richtung. Das war mit Sicherheit jemand. Und dann gibt es halt noch so kleinere Spieler, wie zum Beispiel eben so ein Jacob Ramsey, der sich entwickelt hat bei Eston Villa, der eine Chance bekommen hat. Marco Correa, der, glaube ich, auch in Spanien, werdet ihr mit Sicherheit besser wissen, aber der dort jetzt nicht so der allergrößte war, der von Barcelona einen weg ist, einen Schritt nach zurück gemacht hat, dort aber jetzt richtig gut performt hat, einer der besten Linksverteidiger der Liga geworden ist. Und dann Conor Gallagher, den haben alle genannt, der von Chelsea verliehen hat an Crystal Palace, dort aber gezeigt, dass er einfach so ein giftiger Spieler ist, immer 120 Prozent gibt, trotzdem fußballerisch echt auch wirklich ordentlich ist, das ist auch nochmal so eine Entwicklung. Luis Diaz, Top-Neu-Verpflichtung, mit dem viele nicht gerechnet hätten, und dann natürlich Christian Eriksen, also dass der natürlich auch nochmal zurückkommt und dann aber sofort wieder dieses Level aufrufen kann, das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht, weil viele schon gemeint hätten, der spielt vielleicht nur noch, in Anführungszeichen, Fußball, weil es halt Spaß macht, aber der hat mit Sicherheit nicht mehr so diesen Drive und vielleicht schonet er sich auch, gab es schon so hinter vorgehaltener Hand so die Vermutungen. Ganz im Gegenteil, der ist so unfassbar gut, also ich habe Brent Ford, der hat die nochmal komplett auf ein neues Level gehielt, weil der einfach eine Sache perfekt macht, der nimmt den Ball, dreht sich und spielt ihn immer nach vorne, genau zum richtigen. Mal lang, mal kurz, aber es hat immer Sinn und es gibt immer Tiefe. Ein unfassbar intelligenter Spieler. Das sind so die Entdeckungen, würde ich mal sagen. Oder ja, Wiederentdeckungen, sagen wir bei Ericson mal.
Ja, aber schön, dass du ihn noch mit reingenommen hast. Das finde ich passt hier sehr gut. Wer waren denn für dich dann so die entscheidenden Trainer in dieser Saison?
Ja gut, Pepp und Klopp sind einfach wirklich herausragende Trainer, das muss man einfach sagen. Graham Potter haben wir schon mal angeschnitten gehabt. Aber meine Entdeckung, ich habe letztens im Spiel gesagt, der hätte wahrscheinlich sogar die Wirecard gerettet. Eddie Howe, der aus Newcastle, die waren ganz unten, da hat keiner mehr mit irgendwas gerechnet. Steve Bruce, der hat die wirklich zugrundegerichtet, taktisch, und dann kommt der dahin, sieht die ersten Spiele auch nicht gut aus, und man denkt sich so, okay, ist dieser Hype schon wieder weg, und dann fängt der an, mit denen zu arbeiten, und du erkennst in jedem Spiel, zu aller Konte, ja, ist es eine Organisation da, ja, okay, ich gebe diesem Team auf jeden Fall das, was es braucht, mehr haben wir noch nicht, aber wir sind zumindest mal kompakt, wir sind organisiert, und dann hoffen wir mal, dass zwei, drei irgendwie durchrutschen, bei Standards oder bei Kontern, und genau das hat funktioniert, er hat genau wirklich gemerkt, dass er hat nur diese Spielertypen, er lässt jetzt so spielen, das war ja in Bournemouth komplett anders, das war ja wirklich technischer Fußball, bei Newcastle war es eher so, okay, ich habe keine anderen Typen momentan, Momentan, wir haben wirklich nur diese zwei Mechanismen, entweder Standards oder Schnelligkeit und dann versuchen wir das irgendwie zu nutzen. Und genau so hat sich's ausgezahlt, und am Ende sind die elfter geworden. Damit hätte keiner mehr gerechnet im Winter. Und das ist wirklich das Makeover der Saison auf jeden Fall. Auch wenn natürlich das jetzt nicht unbedingt viele romantische Gefühle bei dem ein oder anderen hervorbeschwören wird, weil aufgrund der finanziellen Struktur des Clubs, die jetzt da ist, aber das ist wirklich beeindruckend, das aus dieser Mannschaft so gemacht zu haben.
Ja, wirklich interessant, was sich da bei Newcastle getan hat in dieser Saison. Marius, in der Serie A, da laufen so viele interessante Trainer um. Eigentlich in allen drei liegen, über die wir gerade sprechen, möchte ich jetzt gar nicht hier einen Unterschied aufmachen. Aber wer war denn in der Saison für dich besonders hervorzuheben?
Auch hier muss ich dann erst mal natürlich direkt wieder zum Milan springen, denn der Meistertrainer Stefano Pioli, als der vor zweieinhalb Jahren bei Milan übernommen hat, da haben die Fans eigentlich so gesagt, okay, vielleicht macht er mit uns jetzt die Saison noch zu Ende und dann schauen wir mal, dann hauen wir hoffentlich jemanden, der uns wirklich nach oben führen kann. Dann sind ja auch mit Ralf Rangnick Gespräche geführt worden. Aber er hatte die Mannschaft seitdem schon so erreicht und um sich gescharrt, dass ein Zlatan Ibrahimov sich zum Beispiel im Interview gesagt hat, wir müssen mit dem verlängern, sonst bin ich auch weg zum Beispiel. Und wie er sich in den letzten Jahren, also seit er bei Milan ist, entwickelt hat, wie er auch sich taktisch weiterentwickelt hat und was er vor allem auch menschlich für eine große Person ist, das hat er damals in Florenz schon gezeigt, als da wieder Astori gestorben ist, wie er da mit der Mannschaft umgegangen ist und jetzt auch diese junge Mannschaft entwickelt, angeleitet hat, eben was er taktisch daraus gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall der Trainer, der dieser Saison seinen Stempel aufgedrückt hat. Dann habe ich von Hellas und Torino, Juric und Tudor, die habe ich erwähnt. Und dann bin ich dann auch wieder bei Salenitana, die ich eben erwähnt hatte, da hat Davide Nicola erst im Januar übernommen. Da hatte die Mannschaft glaube ich 9 Punkte auf dem Konto und er hat noch geschafft 21 Punkte oder so zu holen. Die sind jetzt bei 31 rausgekommen, haben die Klasse gehalten. Und das ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte. Und er ist, also wenn Felix Magath, der archätypische Feuerwehrmann, ist jetzt vielleicht dann nicht mehr, wenn er heute Abend absteigt, dann ist es Davide Nicola auf jeden Fall in Italien.
Mal gucken, ob du da jetzt nicht gerade etwas gejinkst hast, was das Relegationsrückspiel angeht, das wir heute Abend sehen werden. Alex, wen hast du bei dir auf der Liste als Trainer des Jahres im weitesten Sinne? Also Trainer des Jahres, wahrscheinlich würde ich da Pellegrini wählen, weil er den Pokal mit Betis gewonnen hat, was ein historisches Achievement war. Und weil er ja auch so mit Blick auf La Liga ja auch fünfter geworden ist, ist es auch eine richtig tolle Saison, um Einheim die Champions League eingezogen. Es ist einfach schwer, die Top 4 da oben drüber von ihrem Vier, von dem Thron, von den vier Trönen zu stoßen. Schiefes Bild jetzt. Also eine tolle Saison gespielt, mit dem Pokalsieg sich gekrönt. Den würde ich wahrscheinlich nennen. Aber ich möchte viel mehr Raum zwei Trainern zukommen lassen, die so gar nicht im Blickpunkt der Öffentlichkeit sind, erst recht nicht in Deutschland, aber auch nicht mal in Spanien. Denn zwei Trainer, die mit ihren Mannschaften die Klasse gehalten haben, die aber als Feuerwehrmänner kamen und wirklich ihren Job besser nicht hätten machen können. Sergio González hat Cádiz in der Liga gehalten, hat das im Januar das Amt von Alvaro Severa übernommen und von 18 Spielen nur fünf verloren, dabei drei gegen Top-6-Teams. Unter anderem hat er aber viele andere Top-Teams schlagen können oder ärgern können. Also beispielsweise im Camp Nou gewonnen gegen Villarreal gewonnen, Real Madrid einen Punkt abgetrotzt und auch dem FC Sevilla einen Punkt abgetrotzt. Und so eben als Trainer von Cádiz, mit Cádiz am letzten Spieltag die Klasse gehalten, hätte ich persönlich so nicht für möglich gehalten, weil er eine Saison vorher mit Valladolid mehr oder minder sang und klanglos abgestiegen ist. Deswegen war ich auch nicht so überzeugt von der Trainer-Einstellung von Cádiz, um ehrlich zu sein, hätte ihnen das nicht zugetraut, dass sie die Klasse halten. Hat er aber toll gemacht. Punkteschnitt von 1,39, Sergio. F11-pester Punkteschnitt aller La Liga-Trainer mit einem Bottom-3-Team. Zum Vergleich, nur damit man ein bisschen eine Perspektive hat, mit Blick auf die Bundesliga-Bowl-Svenson, der einen phänomenalen Job mit Mainz gemacht hat, der ja 8er wurde in Mainz, hat den gleichen Punkteschnitt, 1,39. Der Bo-Svenson der spanischen Meisterschaft, das ist auch schön. Ja, das hast du jetzt gesagt. Aber nur um eine Perspektive ein bisschen zu haben, mit einem Abstiegsteam, so eine tolle Leistung zu liefern, ist wirklich toll. Und ähnliche Kategorie ist das, was Javier Aguirre gemacht hat. Der alte Fahrernsmann, jetzt kommst du wieder mit der Felix Maggaten Mexikos. Er liegt aber nahe, war ja früher Mexikonationaltrainer, keine Ahnung, wie viele Stationen in den letzten 20 Jahren, kam auch hinten raus für die letzten neun Spiele bei Mallorca und hat nur vier dieser neun Spiele verloren. Die letzten drei ungeschlagen, davon die letzten zwei gewonnen und sich so am letzten Spieltag gerettet. Also auch eine richtig, richtig tolle Leistung gezeigt. Da haben die Feuerwehrmänner funktioniert. Er hat einen Punkteschnitt von 1,44 in diesen neun Spielen. Zehn bester Punkteschnitt aller Ligatrainer. Nur um das ein bisschen in Perspektive zu setzen. Also zwei Feuerwehrmänner oder zwei Trainer-Einstellungen, die absolut perfekt funktioniert haben für zwei sehr kleine, vom Abstiegs bedrohte Clubs. Das sollte man schon auch lobend erwähnen, denn klappt ja nicht immer so ein Trainerwechsel.
Also der Steffen Baumgrad von der Liga kann man das so sagen.
Ja, wie gesagt, Aguirre ist ja 75 oder so, deswegen ein ziemlicher Wandervogel zuletzt gewesen. Deswegen der Vergleich mit Magath. Irgendeinen müssen wir jetzt nehmen. So ein harter Hund ist ja auch bekannt, also hat viel Erfahrung natürlich, aber ist eher als so harter Hund und Schleifer, der dann halt meinetwegen auch mit 20 Prozent Ballbesitz und drei Torschützen irgendwie in 1-0 outgrindet. Aber es kann eben reichen, wenn die Mannschaft das adaptiert, was er macht. Letztes Jahr hat er beinahe Leganes in der Liga gehalten, da hat es ganz, ganz knapp nicht geklappt. Dieses Jahr hat Mallorca gesagt, das hat uns gefallen, was der letzte Mal als Feuerwehrmann gemacht hat, haben sie ihn eingestellt und er hat die Klasse gehalten. Also alles richtig gemacht, Mallorca und Cardis. Überhaupt ein spannendes Saisonfinale, was den Abstiegskampf angeht. Mallorca und Cardis haben sich gerettet, Granada noch abgerutscht auf den 18. Tabellenplatz. Ja, sehr dramatisch gestern. Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Wenn wir ein bisschen versuchen, in die Zukunft zu schauen, mit Blick auf die nächste Saison, was glaubst du, wer wird in der Zukunft für Furore sorgen in La Liga? Gibt es da einen Geheimtipp? Boah, da sind wir wieder beim Thema. Eigentlich ist die Tabelle ziemlich festgefahren. Wenn du mich heute fragen würdest, wie lauten die Top 7 nächstes Jahr, ich würde sagen, genauso wie dieses Jahr. Ja, leider eine langweilige Antwort, aber Real Madrid, Barca, Atletico und Sevilla sind so viel besser normalerweise als die Konkurrenz. Betis wäre fast dran gewesen, da in die Top 4 zu kommen, aber es braucht halt auch sehr, sehr schwache Enttäuschung der Saisons von Barca, Atletico und Sevilla, damit die Top 4 geknackt werden können. Alle drei waren sehr enttäuschend in dem Jahr, haben underperformed, haben schlecht gespielt, haben wenig Punkte geholt und trotzdem hat es für Betis nicht gereicht. Deswegen, was soll da Hoffnung machen? Also ich fürchte, so viel wird sich nächstes Jahr da nicht wirklich ändern und ja, ob jetzt Real, Barca oder Atletico Meister wird, ich glaube für den geneigten deutschen Zuschauer ist das jetzt auch nicht so die prickelnde Vorhersage. Okay, dann muss ich dir gleich die Frage danach stellen, was wird dir denn in Erinnerung bleiben, auch noch in drei, vier, fünf Jahren von dieser Saison? Gibt es unvergessliche Anekdoten? Also ich möchte wieder zurück zu Manuel Pellegrini, denn es gab wirklich eine spannende Anekdote, und zwar seine Trainingsanzug-Marotte. Statistik-Freunde haben herausgefunden, dass er 63 Prozent der Spiele gewinnt, wenn er einen alten, nicht ganz so schönen Kappa-Trainingsanzug stellt. Er trägt, er gestellt von der Mannschaft von Bethes. Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Trainingsanzug, den sie in den 90ern im Kick zu kaufen gab. Also 63 Prozent der Spiele gewinnt er, wenn er dieses Ding trägt. Er gewinnt aber nur 39 Prozent der Spiele, wenn er ihn nicht trägt. Und was hat er dann im Pokalfinale gemacht, wo man sich ja normalerweise fein in den Anzug anzieht? Er hat im Pokalfinale dieses Ding getragen, seinen Trainingsanzug und hat den Pokal damit gewonnen. Also Aberglaube hat sich durchgesetzt. Historisches Achievement mit seinem Trainingsanzug als Marotte. Das ist so für mich die Anekdote der Saison gewesen. Und wir alle wissen natürlich, dass er damit der Udo Lattek von La Liga ist. Immer diese Vergleiche. Ich habe noch hinten draußen einen verrückten, aber witzigen Statistikrekord. Iñaki Williams hat sechs Jahre lang in Folge kein einziges Spiel verpasst. Wir sprechen von 233 Spielen in Folge absoluter La Liga-Rekord. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Rekorde in anderen Ligen sind. Vielleicht weiß das der eine oder andere. Also in Deutschland ist es Sepp Mayer mit 445 glaube ich. Aber in Folge? Genau, in Folge tatsächlich auch. Nie verletzt, nie krank, nie allein im Zeitalter von Corona. Jetzt ist das ja besonders, dass du nicht mal ein, zwei Wochen mit Corona ausfällst. Nicht mal das. Letztmals hat er gefehlt im April 2016. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Nicht schlecht.
Wahnsinn, die gerade Christian Günther vom SC Freiburg mit Andi 120 spielen, glaube ich, vorne.
Richtig krass.
Das liebe ich, dass man uns einfach unsere bescheuerte Statistiken hinwerfen kann. Und da blühen wir auf einmal alle auf. Da blühen sie alle auf. Aber sechs Jahre in Folge, kein Spiel verpassen. Wie geht denn so was? Ich habe es zu Nils vorhin im Podcast gesagt. Und wenn du dir mal am, weiß ich nicht, am Tisch irgendwie den kleinen C stößt und das passiert dann Freitagabend oder ich verpasse das Spiel am Samstag oder Sonntag, das wäre völlig normal. Aber nicht mal das. Also wirklich, wirklich krass. Und er ist Stürmer und ziemlich schneller. Ja genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen, er ist jetzt nicht Torhüter oder so. Genau, er ist nicht Torhüter oder ein Verteidiger, sondern er ist Stürmer ziemlich schnell. Die sind ja normalerweise anfällig für Muskelverletzungen. Grüße an den Belé und Hazard und Bale und Co. Der hat nichts, der Typ. Ich weiß nicht, wie er das schafft. Also absoluter Wahnsinn. Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr bemerkenswerte Statistik.
Das muss man sagen.
So, Yogi, dann darfst du jetzt noch uns liefern. Wer wird für Furore sorgen und woran wirst du dich immer erinnern?
Ich habe gerade überlegt, woran ich mich immer erinnern werde. Das ist echt für mich schwierig. Diese Anekdoten, würde ich echt sagen, bin ich echt schlecht drin. Es gibt natürlich sicherlich so Dinge. Das Jahr haben wir schon besprochen, wo wir uns auf jeden Fall erinnern werden. Das ist die Geschichte mit Newcastle United, dass die übernommen haben. Das kann man dann auch verknüpfen. Ich glaube, dass die im nächsten Jahr schon für Furore sorgen werden. Ob die jetzt gleich in die Top 6 reinbrechen, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich tippe, 7, 8 wird schon möglich sein. Ich bin gespannt, was die im Sommer machen. Das ist mit Sicherheit das, worauf wir achten müssen. Die werden für Furore sorgen. Die Frage ist, kann Ten Hag wirklich etwas umdrehen? Wir haben gestern im Kollegenkreis gewitselt, dass die einzige Liga der Welt, in der du es hinbekommst, einen Umbruch zu schaffen und trotzdem Meister zu werden, die Bundesliga ist. Das ist in Englisch gnadenlos. Es könnte wirklich sein, dass, wenn er zu viel umreißt, dass er ein Problem bekommt, denn die sind jetzt schon Sechster. Was ist denn, wenn die umbrechen und er die Hälfte der Mannschaft austauscht und es nicht gleich funktioniert? Was ist, wenn die Elfter werden? Dreht dann alle durch, wie er bei Gang 6 jetzt schon durchgedreht wird. Das könnte negative Furore sein, New Class könnte die in Anführungszeichen positive Furore werden. Und dann so Anekdoten. Da gibt es natürlich schon so viele lustige Dinge, die durch passiert sind irgendwo. Aber so die ganz großen Dinge, ehrlich gesagt, fallen mir jetzt momentan gerade nicht ein. Bin ich gerade echt am überlegen, aber bin ich raus, glaube ich.
Da musst du dir auch nichts aus der Nase ziehen, weil sonst ist es ja auch keine richtige bedenkenswerte Anekdote. Dann bleibt uns nur noch der Blick nach Italien. Marius, wer wird in der nächsten Saison für Furore sorgen? Woran wirst du dich für immer erinnern?
Was ich hoffe und woran ich auch fest glaube, ist, dass in seinem zweiten Jahr Jose Mourinho aus der Roma ein Team machen wird, das vielleicht nicht bis ganz zum Schluss, aber zumindest lange Strecken der Saison ein Kandidat sein wird, wo wir uns darüber unterhalten werden, ob sie vielleicht mal Meister werden können. Also ich finde, es ist ja bei ihm immer so ein bisschen zweischneidig. Auch als er die Roma übernommen hat, da dachten sie, okay, jetzt ist bei ihm, Tottenheim war schon nicht mehr so groß und jetzt kommt die Roma, das ist noch mal eine Stufe darunter, jetzt ist bei ihm der Lack irgendwie komplett ab. Aber er hat gezeigt, erst mal, dass er auch in der Lage ist, taktisch sich noch weiterentwickeln zu können. Er lässt bei der Roma keinen typischen Mourinho-Fußball aus den letzten 20 Jahren spielen, sondern lässt da einen offensiven Ball spielen. Das ist auch teilweise sehr gefällig, mit Tammy Abraham einen super Stürmer geholt, der 17. Saisontore geschossen hat. Ich glaube, wenn die Mannschaft noch ein bisschen gefestigter ist, wenn sie im Sommer noch ein, zwei Verstärkungen dazu bekommen, dass sie auf jeden Fall nächste Saison die Champions League-Plätze und vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen Glück hinten raus ganz oben angreifen können. Und da passt das dann eigentlich auch anekdotisch, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber auch statistisch, dass er jetzt ja am Mittwoch noch die Chance hat, der erste Trainer zu werden, der alle drei aktuellen Pokale dann aus der Van der Wever gewonnen haben werden könnte. Weil er ja noch im Conference-Finale gegen Feyenoord steht. Und das ist natürlich, Mourinho kommt irgendwo hin und sagt, ich hole euch Silverware und dann schafft er das bei der Roma, die seit 2000 keinen Titel mehr gewonnen hat. Das ist natürlich dann auch eine nette Geschichte. Was auf jeden Fall auch in Erinnerung bleiben wird, ist, dass der Milan-Titel eigentlich, da haben dann viele Leute gesagt, jetzt ist es klar, als am vergangenen, also vor anderthalb Wochen, am vorletzten Spieltag, Theo Hernandez aus einem 100-Meter-Sprint heraus, dass das entscheidende Tor geschossen hat gegen Atalanta. Das wird in jedem Jahresrückblicks-Video in Italien auf jeden Fall die Szene sein. Und Anekdote auf jeden Fall auch. Salenitana, wie sie sich gerettet haben, habe ich gerade ja schon kurz gesagt, wie Davide Nicolai da den Turnaround geschafft hat. Absolut, absoluter Wahnsinn im Grunde genommen. Die haben im Winter eine komplett neue Elf gekauft, also einen Torwart und zehn neue Spieler. Die haben nicht immer so komplett zusammengespielt, aber sie haben quasi den Kader nochmal komplett umgekrempelt und haben eben damit den Klassen halt geschafft. Und er hat vor ein paar Wochen gesagt, wenn wir es schaffen, dann laufe ich zu Fuß zum Vatikan und zum Papst. Und ich weiß nicht, ob er heute schon auf dem Weg ist mit ein bisschen Restalkohol oder ob das jetzt die Tage in Angriff nimmt. Von Salerno aus sind das so 250, 300 Kilometer, glaube ich. Er macht das auf jeden Fall. Er hat mit Crotone schon mal eine sehr wahnsinnige Rettungsaktion gestartet. Er kommt aus dem Piemont, aus der Nähe von Turin. Und ist dann von Crotone, das ist so an der Sohle des Stiefels quasi. Ist aber mit dem Fahrrad einmal hochgefahren nach Turin, nach ganz oben. Also er hat da gezeigt, dass er diese Ankündigungen wahr macht. Und das finde ich auf jeden Fall auch erinnerungswürdig.
Ihr drei, dann haben wir es doch geschafft. Ich danke euch dreien ganz herzlich und stellvertretend auch noch mal in Abwesenheit allen anderen. Zum einen für die Premier League waren in diesem Jahr mit dabei. Uli Hebel, Hendrik Buchheister und herzlichen Dank jetzt stellvertretend an dich. Jogi Hebel, danke, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Ja, mir ebenso. Und herzlichen Dank an für La Liga. Fabian Pakulat, Nies Kern und jetzt Alex Truica. Alex, danke, dass du diese etwas längere Sendung auf dich genommen hast. Sehr gerne, es ist mir immer eine Freude und Ehre, hier dabei zu sein. Macht immer großen Spaß, danke. Ja, das werden wir auf jeden Fall weitermachen. Mir macht es auch richtig viel Spaß, muss ich sagen. Und herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard von der Serie A, Mario Rieker für die Serie A und natürlich jetzt auch Marius Soyke, die man, also euch kann man ja auch bei Serie Amore hören. Überhaupt euch alle kann man hören, das habe ich jetzt gar nicht geplagt. Also Click and Rush natürlich für die Premier League, den Tiki Taka Podcast für La Liga und Serie Amore für die Serie A. Danke dir, lieber Marius, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Danke dir, Max, für die Einladung. Ich schließe mich den beiden Kollegen an. Es macht großen Spaß, hier dabei zu sein und gerne nächste Saison wieder.
Ja, wenn es nach mir geht, auf jeden Fall. Und wir machen an dieser Stelle jetzt weiter mit Alexis Menuge und der Ligue A. Jetzt habe ich Alexis Menuge bei mir zur Ligue A noch am Sonntagabend. Es ist noch alles ganz frisch. Alexis, wie hoch ist dein Puls? Und schön, dass du hier bist.
Danke, Max, freue mich auch. Der Puls war vor allem am Samstagabend richtig hoch, weil wir hatten den letzten Spieltag der Ligue 1-Saison und zehn Spiele parallel, 35 Treffer. Wir hatten ja in der Ligue 1, waren wir gewohnt, vor zehn Jahren noch viele 0-0 zu haben. 2,1, 2,2 Tore pro Spielung dieser Saison haben wir im Endeffekt 2,85. Das ist der beste Wert seit 2002. Ich durfte gestern wieder so an Lens Monaco kommentieren, Ausgleich in der Nachspielzeit für Lens. Monaco war sicher auf dem zweiten Platz, und auf einmal kommt dieser Ausgleich, und dadurch rutscht der Marseille auf Platz zwei und darf also direkt in die Champions League starten im September, wer in Monaco zwei Quali-Runde überstehen muss. Aber natürlich die große Nachricht war, dass der Mbappé, das Kapitel war seine Zukunft anbelangt, ist endlich mal vorbei, eineinhalb Jahre, und wir wissen, was er macht, er bleibt in Paris, und nicht nur ein Jahr, sondern drei Jahre. Und ich glaube, das wird viel Stoff geben dazu und viele Themen im Sommer, weil der Verein steht vor einer Revolution bei den Verantwortlichen und natürlich auch, was der Kader anbelangt.
Ja, wir müssen tatsächlich mit Mbappé, glaube ich, beginnen, weil das eben so eine wichtige Nachricht war, auch wenn das eigentlich ja gar nicht zu dieser Saisonbilanz mit dazu gehört. Ich habe da unglaublich hohe Zahlen gelesen, die herumgehen. Gleichzeitig hat man aber auch gehört, dass das Angebot von Real Madrid jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel niedriger gewesen sein soll. Was glaubst du denn, sind die Gründe für Mbappé bei PSG zu bleiben?
Also, laut meiner Informationen hatte sich Mbappé für Real Madrid ursprünglich bis Freitag früh entschieden. Und danach gab es noch ein entscheidendes Treffen mit den Verantwortlichen von Paris Saint-Germain, die ihn umgeschrieben haben und nicht aus finanziellen Gründen, weil er kriegt auf jeden Fall 100 Millionen Euro Netto für die Unterschrift und nicht 300, wie die Spanier behaupten. Und dazu 50 Millionen Netto im Jahr Gehalt. Also so oder so wird er ab dem 1.7. der teuerste Spieler aller Zeiten. Der bestbezahlte. Er bekommt aber unglaublich viel Macht, und das kann man natürlich diskutieren bzw. kritisieren. Er ist 23 Jahre alt, aber er soll nicht nur die Kapitänsbinde bekommen, aber sogar Mitsprache erreicht haben bei der Trainerwahl, die ansteht. Also Pochettino wird wohl morgen Montag endgültig entlassen. Leonardo, der Sportdirektor, ist schon letzte Nacht entlassen worden. Und da hat er auch Mitspracherecht gehabt, weil er mit den Brasilianern gar nicht klarkam. Er kam aber gut klar mit Pochettino nur. Kylian hat gemerkt, dass Pochettino nicht der geeignete Trainer ist, um diese verrückte Kabine im Griff zu haben. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass er auch weiß, wer der nächste Trainer wird, weil ansonsten hätte er nicht für gleich drei Jahre unterschrieben. Drei Jahre ist schon viel. Er redet nicht von zwei plus eins, sondern von drei Jahren bis 2025. Das bedeutet in meinen Augen, dass er sich schon mittelfrissig für Peugeot engagiert, dass er von Real Madrid nichts mehr wissen will. Ich glaube, das ist auch umgekehrt der Fall mittlerweile. Und auch was der Kader betrifft, bei Abgängen, vor allem bei Zugegen, wird Mbappé sein Wort haben. Zum Beispiel wissen wir aus sicheren Quellen, dass er gerne Neymar loshaben möchte und dass er auf der Gegenseite als Nr. 6 Oralien Choumini von Monaco haben möchte.
Das sind ganz schön viele Informationen. Alexi, wie bewertest du denn das als Beobachter, dass ein Spieler, ein junger Spieler, so viel Mitsprache in einem Verein erhält? Gibt es dafür andere Beispiele oder erleben wir das gerade zum ersten Mal?
Ich glaube schon, dass wir es zum ersten Mal erleben, in dieser Masse, in dieser, in dieser, in dieser, so viel Macht zu bekommen, obwohl er, wie gesagt, nur 23 ist, natürlich ist er ein Ausnahme-Stürmer, natürlich ist er momentan vielleicht der Beste der Welt, zusammen mit Karim Benzema und vielleicht noch mit Robert Lewandowski. Aber es ist schon gefährlich, glaube ich, dass ein Spieler so viel Macht bekommt. Es ist für mich das Zeichen, das Parc des St. Jean-Jacques immer noch nicht verstanden hat, dass eigentlich der Verein über jeden Spieler stehen muss. Und das machen die Verantwortlichen weiterhin anders. Erst war Neymar über den Verein, dann Messi und auf einmal Mbappé, der alles entscheiden darf, der eigentlich selber den Kader gestalten möchte. Und stellt man sich vor, Kunte oder warum nicht Joachim Löw unterschreibt, morgen für drei Jahre. Und im Oktober heißt es nach einem 1 zu 1 zuhausegen Salzburg und einer 2 zu 3 Niederlage bei, wer wäre dann Top 4, zum Beispiel Brüge oder sogar, keine Ahnung, Sporting Portugal oder Benfica Lissabon. Ja, was macht man dann? Dann läuft er zum Alkaleifi hoch und sagt, Boss, wir müssen mit Löw aufhören oder mit Kunte. Es geht nicht weiter, er kommt mit uns nicht klar. Und weil Mbappé der Chef ist, heißt es, die Chefs werden sofort seine Wünsche erfüllen. Also das halte ich schon für gefährlich. Auf der anderen Seite, das ist der Hauptgrund, warum Mbappé verlängert hat. In einem halben Jahr haben wir die WM in Katar und das war der größte Wunsch und das größte Ziel der Scheiß in Doha, dass Mbappé während ihrer WM nach wie vor das Paris Saint-Germain-Trikotrik, das war die höchste Priorität und die zweite. Man hat ihm versprochen, dass er bei den Olympischen Spielen in zwei Jahren in Paris auflaufen darf. Das ist ausgemacht worden, zusammen mit Alka Laifi und mit Staatspräsident Emmanuel Macron, weil normalerweise ein Spieler, der die Europamessenschaft bestreiten wird, und das wird der Fall sein in Deutschland, wenn sich natürlich Frankreich qualifiziert, aber dann hätte Mbappé Olympische Spiele plus EM in einem Sommer. Aber das ist ihm versprochen worden und deswegen hat er auch gesagt, ich bleibe doch in Paris, scheinbar wäre ihm dieser Wunschbarkeit nicht unbedingt erfüllt gewesen.
Okay, na gut, das muss PSG letztlich selbst wissen, was man da tut. Ich glaube, da werden wir viele, viele Themen haben, die dann nicht immer mit Sportlichen zu tun haben werden. Jetzt ist das ja eigentlich ein Rückblick auf diese Saison der Ligue 1. Und die erste Frage, die ich allen anderen auch gestellt habe, war eben die nach dem Meister. Da haben wir mit PSG jemanden, der mit 15 Punkten Vorsprung gewonnen hat, der auch letztlich mit seinem 5 zu 0 am letzten Spieltag gegen Metz auch im Abstiegskampf noch ein Wörtchen mitgesprochen hat. Ist es nur die individuelle Qualität, die PSG in diesem Jahr besser gemacht hat oder gibt es noch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber hinaus zu dieser Meisterschaft?
Ich denke, dass die berauffolgenden Mannschaften, vor allem die auf dem Papier heiß gehandelt wurden zum Beginn der Saison, Olympique Lyon, Eismontaco, vor allem, wenn Monaco eine sehr schwache Hinrunde gespielt hat, deswegen auch die Entlassung von Kovac. Nicht zu vergessen, vor genau zwei Monaten war Monaco nur auf Platz 9, mit neun Zählernrückständen auf Platz 3. Und dann gab es neun Siege in Folge, bis auf das 2-2 gestern in Lens. Und deswegen hat man sich dann auf das Podium oder für die Champions League Qualifikation qualifiziert. Aber man war nicht konstant genug. Bilil zum Beispiel vor einem Jahr. Nicht vergessen, Bilil war Meister vor einem Jahr mit einer eingeschworenen Truppe. Und Lyon hat vielleicht die katastrophalste Saison gespielt seit ihm, seit dieser tollen Ära damals zu Beginn des Jahrhunderts. Ja, auf dem Transfermarkt komplett daneben gelegen, bei Schalkeiri, aber leider Gottes auch bei Jérôme Boateng, der komplette Auswahl war und der auch keine Zukunft bei OL hat. Und wenn du solche Mannschaften hast, die keine Konstanz haben, die sich zerfleischen, die keine gute Stimmung in der Kabine haben, dann ist es für Paris ein einfaches Spiel, ohne unbedingt alles zu geben in der Meisterschaft. Und Paris hatte auch das Glück, aber Glück muss man auch können, in der Nachspielzeit vor allem, der Hinrunde, die Spiele zu entscheiden. Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, Max, wäre heute bei Real oder bei Liverpool gewesen und nicht in Paris. Dann wäre Paris anscheinend mal weder Meister geworden, noch ins Champions League-Finale, Achtelfinale eingezogen. Ich glaube, die wären sogar in der Ruhmphase bereits ausgeschieden, weil er so ein entscheidender Faktor war.
Faszinierend, was ein Spieler dann doch noch ausmachen kann im Teamsportfußball. Dann lass mal hinter PSG gucken, da warten ja dann auch eher so ein bisschen die Überraschungen der Saison. Zählt da für dich Marseille mit dazu?
Ja, auf den ersten Blick schon, weil ich dachte auf dem Papier, dass Lyon und Monaco stärker und besser besetzt sind. Marseille war auch lange im Europapokal, ein bisschen das Halbfinale der Europakonferenz liegt dabei, ausgeschieden gegen Ferne und Rotterdam. Man hat nicht unbedingt spielerisch überzeugt, beziehungsweise war man jetzt im letzten Saison-Titel müde, einsfallslos. Aber gestern war es echt fantastisch, Marseille 4-0 gegen Straßburg, der auch noch nach Europa wollte vor 65.000 Zuschauern. Und das ist schon eine gute Nachricht, dass Marseille direkt qualifiziert ist, weil ich denke, Marseille wäre durch die zwei Quali-Runden im August nicht weitergekommen, weil man da kaum vorbereitet ist, weil man sich da schwer tut gegen Mannschaften, wie zum Beispiel Monaco letzte Saison mit Prag oder Donetsk, an dem man gescheitert ist in den Playoffs, Monaco halte ich dafür besser ausgerichtet. Denn ich denke, dass bis auf die Showmenü werden alle Stammkräfte am Fürstentum bleiben. Mit Jorge Sampaoli hat Marseille natürlich einen zerrückten, aber besessenen Trainer, der die Mannschaft bis in die Haarspitze motivieren kann, auch spielerisch eine Handschrift verpasst hat. Das ist schon sehr interessant. Er hat jetzt vier bis fünf neue Zugehende gefordert. Es wird schwer, seine Wünsche zu erfüllen. Auf der anderen Seite hat Marius jetzt 70 Millionen Euro durch die Champions League-Falli eingenommen. Und auch einen neuen Kontakt für die Liga, wo jeder Verein 16,5 Millionen Euro für die neue Saison bekommt, damit die Liga nicht pleite geht oder die Vereine. Ich denke, dass Marius seinen zweiten Platz im großen und ganzen verdient hat.
Und damit ja auch den End-Sprint gegen Monaco gewonnen. Du hast es vorhin schon mal angedeutet, da würde ich aber gerne noch mal genauer drauf gucken. Niko Kovac wird vor zwei Monaten entlassen auf Rang 9, rangiert Monaco da. Jetzt ist man bis zu einem späten 2 zu 2 eigentlich auf Rang 2 vorgerückt. Jetzt ist es am Ende nur die Qualifikation zur Champions League gewonnen. Was hat sich denn da verändert?
Wenn man Philipp Cremont, der belgische Trainer, mit Niko Kovac vergleicht, Niko Kovac kam mit Fofana, nicht klar, Fofana bildet mit Jormini das Duo vor der Abwehr, also sehr wichtig für den Zusammenhalt und für die Stabilität dieser Elf. Und Niko Kovac hat auch Probleme scheinbar gehabt, also kam nicht wirklich gut klar mit Vincent Bernier, der französische Nationalstürmer. 25 Buden erzielt allein in der Liga in dieser Saison, gestern wieder erfolgreich gewesen und der Kapitän. Und seit Clément das Abend von Kovac übernommen hat, hat Bernier wieder seine beste Form erreicht. Das sind die zwei Schlüsselspieler gewesen, sodass Monaco wieder auf der Siegersstraße zurückkam. Das war wichtig, weil im März hatte der russische Milliardär und eigentlich immer von Monaco gedroht, wenn wir nicht nach Europa gehen, dann werde ich alles ändern. Der Trainer, der Sportdirektor und sogar der Vizepräsident. Und scheinbar nur dieser Letzte wird den Verein verlassen. Man wird auf Kontinuität setzen. Monaco hat seine Automatismen. Und um kein großes oder zu großes Risiko einzugehen, wird man die Mannschaft zusammenhalten, sodass man die besten Chancen hat, die Qualirunden erfolgreich zu bestreiten im August und dann sich für die Grundphase der Champions League zu qualifizieren.
Hat denn der russische Eigentümer noch Zugriff auf Monaco? Ist es keine Abramovic-Situation bei Monaco?
Der Unterschied ist halt, dass Reboloffe seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr nach Russland darf. Da gab es ein Problem mit dem russischen Präsidenten. Und deswegen hat er mit Russland eigentlich nichts mehr zu tun. Er wohnt in Monaco. Laut den französischen Medien und Kollegen hat er es da nicht zu befürchten. Er wird auch seine Position als Monacos Präsident weiterhin ausüben dürfen. Er ist leidenschaftlich dabei. Er will unbedingt, dass Monaco mindestens jedes Saisonende aufs Podium kommt. Und vielleicht nächste Saison Paris Saint-Germain ein bisschen ärgern darf.
Gut, auch da ist natürlich die Frage, wie Mbappé das in Zukunft gestalten wird bei PSG. Dann haben wir, wenn ich jetzt die Tabelle weiter nach unten gehe, Ren und Nizza. Du hast uns noch im März erzählt, Nizza wird in die Champions League kommen. Alexi, was ist da passiert?
Ja, sehr schwache Rückrunde vor allem. Der letzte Spiel-Saison-Titel war sehr enttäuschend. Vielleicht hat man da auf dem Transfermarkt nicht die besten Spieler geholt. Dante ist jetzt 38, man hat mit ihm um ein Jahr verlängert. Kann man eigentlich gut zurück nach seinem Kreuzbandriss. Aber man hat auch gesehen, dass er in die Jahre geht zu Ende der Saison, schwache Leistungen. Eine nach der anderen absolviert. Ich war vor zwei oder zehn Tagen in Nizza gegen Stadtiziane im Stadion, zum ersten Mal dort. Zu Halbzeit lag es schon 0-2. Und dann hat Nizza innerhalb von sieben, acht Minuten drei Treffer gezählt, sodass man die Partie drehen konnte. Genau wie gestern. 0-2 in der Reims, zu Halbzeit. Und dann macht Ony DeLore wieder drei Kisten, sodass man zumindest in der Europakonferenz liegen darf. Aber viel Unruhe um Nizza. Und ich glaube auch, dass es die Tatsache ist, dass Jim Redcliffe sich bei Chelsea angeboten hat, den Verein zu kaufen, dass er bereit war, 1,5 bis 2 Milliarden Euro auszugeben, nachdem er für nur 100 Millionen Euro, in Anführungszeichen natürlich, 100 Millionen Euro Nizza gekauft hat, hat schon für eine gewisse Unruhe gesorgt. An der Cote d'Azur. Auch bei den Spielern, bei den Verantwortlichen. Jetzt heißt es, Redcliffe bleibt, er wird die Mannschaft noch einmal richtig verstärken. Christoph Gelfi, der Trainer, der vor einem Jahr ja viel zur Meisterschaft führte, wird wohl bleiben, auch wenn sein Name bei Paris Saint-Germain kursiert. Aber klar, das fünfte Platz, der nur zu Europakonferenz-League-Qualifikationen führt, ist sehr enttäuschend für Nizza. Und die Rückung war einfach zu schlecht. Auch Dauberberg viel zu wenig gezeigt. Ein Phantom geworden mittlerweile, der dänische Nationalspieler. Wie gesagt, danke, dass du es schon erwähnt hast. Und Guiri war vielleicht der beste League-Anspieler der Hinrunde. Nichts mehr zu sehen, seit Februar kein Tor erzielt, keine Folge gegeben. Also es gibt schon einige Baustellen, Christophe Galtier und die Spieler von Nizza.
Und gehört dann im Umkehrschluss dazu, Rent, auch zu den positiven Überraschungen der Saison? Haben immerhin die zweitbeste Offensive nach Péché mit 82 Toren?
Also die zeigen oder die machen am meisten Spaß in der Liga. Die zeigen ja den attraktivsten Spielstil. Dank Trainer Bruno Genesio, also dem macht es immer Spaß, zuzuschauen. Es gibt nie Null Null, es gibt immer Chancen. Ein toller Verein, der sich gut entwickelt hat, stetig weiterentwickelt hat die letzten Jahren. Das ist schon in der Europa-Konferenz League vor drei Jahren, in der Champions League-Grubenphase gewesen zum ersten Mal. Natürlich war das Podium oder der ganz große Traum, das Ziel war die europäische Qualifikation. Ohne den Ausgleich gestern in der Nachspielzeit bei Lille wäre dann Rhein nur Fünfter geworden und dadurch nicht der Vierter. Also einer wäre dann in der Konferenz League gewesen. Aber es ist eine Mannschaft, die diesen vierten Pass mehr als verdient hat. Mein Auge hätte sogar mehr die Champions League verdient gehabt, aber in den Schlussmomenten hat man ein bisschen geschwächt. Wie bei den in der Lage in Straßburg vor vier, fünf Wochen oder gestern beim 2-2 in Lille, wo der Meister 2021 eigentlich nichts mehr zu gewonnen hatte. Das war schon ein bisschen enttäuschend, aber Rhein hat seinen Auftrag gefüllt. Spielerisch, auch ergebnistechnisch. Ich glaube, auf diese Mannschaft wird es sich lohnen, ein Auge zu werfen in die Europa League und auch in der Meisterschaft, wo wohl einige Spieler heiß begehrt sind.
Dann können wir ja schauen, was da noch passiert. Was gibt es darüber hinaus für Überraschungen in dieser Saison? Oder müssen wir schon zu den Enttäuschungen übergehen?
Ich glaube, Mannschaften, die Bordeaux und St. Etienne verabschiedet haben, bzw. die noch in der Relegation sind, müssen sie natürlich nicht nur enttäuschen, sondern bekommen die Quittung für schlechte Arbeit. Das ist vergleichbar mit der HSV, mit dem Abstieg vor vier Jahren oder vor einer Saison mit Schalke 04 und Werder Bremen. Wenn du schlechte Arbeit hast, bekommst du für das Spiel die Quittung. Das war bei Girona Bordeaux genauso der Fall. Die schlechteste Abwehr ist unter den top europäischen fünf liegen. Ich glaube, bei 85, da musst du mich korrigieren. Aber auf jeden Fall eine Katastrophe. Trotz des 4 zu 2 Sieges ist es noch gestern in Brest. Aber da gab es so viele Probleme, die in den letzten Jahren schon schlecht erwirtschaftet werden. Als Eigentümer, Amerikaner, die sich nicht wirklich identifiziert haben mit dem Verein, die mehr Geld verdienen wollten, als die Mannschaft sorgfältig und strukturiert zu verstärken. Und Saint-Étienne genauso. Hätte gestern Saint-Étienne in Norden nicht ausgeglichen, kurz vor Schluss wäre er in die Grünen. Der noch Rekordmeister ist, zusammen mit PSG mit zehn Meistertiteln, heute auch in der Zweiten Liga. Und dann dieses Ausgleich dürfen die die Stefanoa zwei Relegationsspielen bestreiten gegen die ehemalige Mannschaft von Giroud, Agios Serra. Im Kampf um den Aufstieg oder den Klassenerhalt in der Liga. Und auch wichtig für dich, für die kommende Saison bei Rauschenfunk, die Liga ist umso dramatischer, weil wir ab 2023, 2025 nur noch 18 Mannschaften haben werden. Das heißt, dass in der kommenden Saison keine Relegationsspiele anstehen, sondern dass vier Mannschaften aus der Liga direkt absteigen und nur zwei aufsteigen dürfen.
Das wird allerdings interessant. Ja, woher kommt die Reduzierung? Warum will man das?
Das war zu der Zeit vor einem Jahr, als die Super League im Gespräch war. Natürlich wird die Champions League aufgestockt, ein bisschen ab 2024. Aber man hat auch gemerkt, dass wenn man ein bisschen die Liga reduziert, dass die vielleicht ein bisschen konkurrenzfähiger wird, weil man hat es wieder in dieser Saison festgestellt, Mannschaften wie Metz, Bordeaux, Saint-Étienne, oder sogar Lorient oder Troyes sind Mannschaften, die sich schwer tun in der Liga 1. Deswegen haben wir uns an die Bundesliga angeboten. Man hat schon vor zwei Jahren den Liga-Pokal abgeschafft. Damit man auch einen entspannteren Spielplan hat. In fünf, sechs Jahren, wenn die Champions League von 27 bis 2030 noch mal aufgestoppt wird, mit vielleicht noch mehr Spielen, dann wird man auf 16 Mannschaften in der Liga ankommen.
Interessante Entwicklung. Aber die Diskussion gibt es ja durchaus auch noch in anderen Ligen, die 20er-Ligen zu reduzieren. Welche Spieler waren denn in der Saison so richtige Entdeckungen? Wenn ich jetzt mal zum Beispiel auf die Torschützenliste gucke, dann haben wir natürlich neben Mbappé, der irgendwie häufiger vorkommt in diesem Segment, habe ich das Gefühl, Ben Yedet, den du schon angesprochen hast, mit 25 Treffern, aber auch Martin Therrien von Rennes mit 21, Moussa Dembélé von Lyon mit 21 Treffern. Aber das sind ja die Stürmer, die einem immer am ehesten auffallen. Darüber hinaus bin ich völlig hilflos, Alexi. Also hilf mir, welche Spieler-Namen sind besonders interessant und sind in Erscheinung getreten in dieser Saison?
Erst einmal möchte ich feststellen und mitteilen, dass die Trojegaliste von den rein französischen Stürmern dominiert wurden. Ich glaube, die ersten 5, 6 sind reine Franzosen. Die hast du schon erwähnt mit Thierry, mit Dembélé und so weiter. De Loro auch mit 18 Treffern an seinem Dreierpark gestern. Auch wenn er seit Kurzem für die algräische Nationalmannschaft spielt. Jetzt hatte ich was vergessen. Thierry ist keine Entdeckung, weil er sich schon bei der Olympiaklinie gezeigt hat. Aber da hatte er sich, oder hatte Schwierigkeiten, sich durchzusetzen. Trotzdem hat er es in dieser Saison durchbrucht. Er hat schon mal einen Anruf von wie jeder schon bekommen. Vielleicht für die Nationalmannschaft. Aber da ist die Konkurrenz so groß, dass es sehr schwer für ihn werden wird. Aber so von seinem Spielstil her, von seiner Eleganz am Ball, den könnte ich mir schon sehr gut in der Bundesliga vorstellen. Auch wenn er sich in der Britannia sehr wohlfühlt. Da bin ich schon sehr überrascht, dass er so viele Treffer als dieser hat. Er ist der einzige Lichtblick bei den Lyonais in dieser traurigen Spielzeit. Eigentlich sagt man über Dembele in Frankreich, er ist ein guter Schwimmer, aber er hat keine Füße. Und in dieser Saison war er ein bisschen effizienter vom generischen Tor. Letzte Saison noch in der zweiten Saisonhälfte bei Atlético de Madrid ausgeliehen. Er hat überhaupt keinen Fuß gefasst. Aber jetzt nach seiner erfolgreichen Spielzeit wird er wieder heiß begehrt. Also schon eine gewisse Überraschung, auch wenn er in Frankreich bekannt ist. Und da werde ich natürlich gespannt, wer von den Jugendtalenten in der Liga in dieser Saison in die Bundesliga wechseln werden. Es ist ja eine Tendenz, eine Mode gewesen in den letzten Jahren. Diese tolle Mode wird sich, glaube ich, fortsetzen. Man hat ja schon den jungen Antonika Si von Straßburg, der Name eins geht, der linksverteidiger, aber natürlich Randale, fantastischer Vorname, Colomoni, der zu der Frankfurter Eintracht wechselt und gleich in die Champions League ran darf. Und wo ich sage, da kommt es auch Navid Vor, ein Nachfolger für Erling Haaland als Nr. 9. Und da spielt, glaube ich, nicht nur Sebastien Allende Rolle, sondern der junge Stürmer Hugo Echidicke von Stadranz. Also da bin ich gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, da können wir ja gespannt sein, haben wir ja schon mal thematisiert, dass da wirklich sehr, sehr viel Talent aus der Liga schon rübergekommen ist in die Bundesliga. Welche Trainer waren denn wichtig? Du hast vorhin schon ein paar Namen genannt, aber lass mal beginnen, wer war für dich der Trainer der Saison?
Schwierige Frage, weil Mannschaften wie Rennes und Schwarzburg, die eigentlich bis zum Schluss im Kampf um Europa dabei waren, bzw. sich rein qualifiziert, Schwarzburg klar gescheitert, aber die hätten wir zum Beispiel nicht erwartet. Aber dort spielt oder trainiert Julien Stéphan, junger französischer moderner Trainer. Er ist der Sohn vom Co-Trainer der Nationalmannschaft. Er prägt ein modernes Spiel mit viel Gegenpressing. Er schaut sich immer an die Bundesliga an. Er hat ziemlich viel Erfolg gehabt. Sein Name wird auch immer wieder gehört bei Olympique Lyon, weil man so dort einen Nachfolger für Peter Boss, der überhaupt nicht erfolgreich war, bzw. genauso erfolgreich wie früher in Dortmund oder Leberkusen, wenn du weißt, was ich meine. Das Marius Yopochekino, nicht erwähnen will, glaube ich, ist normal. Er hat in meinen Augen die Mannschaft keinen Zentimeter weitergebracht in den 18 Monaten, wo er in Paris Saint-Germain ist. Malai ist noch nicht entlassen zu dieser Uhrzeit. Könnte aber was werden. Und natürlich der Trainer von Rhein, wie gesagt, Dank Bruno Genesio, hat Rhein eine affraktive Spielweise gezeigt, hat seinen Fans begeistert. Aber nicht nur seine eigenen Fans. Also, Rhein zu zuschauen ist eine Augenweide. Und das ist der Verdienst von Bruno Genesio. Jorge Sampaoli zu erwähnen von so einer Spielweise ist viel schwieriger, weil er eher ein Vulkan ist als ein Top-Top-Top-Trainer, wie der gute Pep sagt. Und der Trainer von Monaco, Philipp Clément, ihn zu analysieren nach einem halben Jahr, ich glaube, ein bisschen zu früh. Aber er hatte schon Paris Saint-Germain gejagert in der Champions League mit Brügge in der ersten Saisonhälfte, in der Champions League-Hogenphase, auch Leipzig gejagert, auch Manchester City. Und den könnte man, glaube ich, in der nächsten Saison besser beurteilen. Also Genesio und Stephane für mich, die zwei Trainer, die die beste Arbeit erledigt haben in der Liga.
Wie würdest du jetzt im Nachhinein die Saison von Christophe Galtier einordnen, der ja zu Nizza gewechselt ist?
Ja, eine Drei-Plus. Also gut, aber mit einem Fall Malgeschmack, weil die ersten zwei Saison-Titel waren richtig gut, ganz klar. Man war lange auf Chemnitzekurs, man war sehr lange auf Platz zwei. Man hat das Pokalfinale erreicht, aber man hat das Pokalfinale verloren gegen den FC Nord, obwohl man favorit war. Und Nizza hat dieses Spiel gar nicht bestritten. Man hat keinen Fußballgesinn von Nizza im Pokalfinale, und das war schon sehr, sehr frustrierend. Und dann, wie gesagt, die letzten Spieltage kaum erfolgreich gewesen. Zwar defensiv solide agiert, aber nach vorne ging sehr wenig los. Also, bis auf diese zwei Spiele, die ich vorher erwähnt habe. Beim Spiel gegen Santé-Tier und gestern in der Reims hat Nizza so gut wie nie mehr als ein Tor erzählt. Und ich hoffe, dass Galtier Nizza bleibt. Ich glaube, er kann nächste Saison mehr zeigen. Aber wie gesagt, gut. Gute erste Saison, weil es ist nicht einfach, von Ligatour nach Nizza zu wechseln, von einer Meistermannschaft, zu einer Mannschaft, die nicht mehr im Europa-Pokal dabei ist, aber keinerfalls dabei geschmackt, weil das Ende der Saison relativ holprig verlief.
Und dann kannst du jetzt in die Glaskugel gucken, lieber Alexi. Wer wird denn in der nächsten Saison für Furore sorgen? Vielleicht sogar eine Mannschaft, die jetzt das internationale Geschäft verpasst hat. Und deswegen wird ja wahrscheinlich relativ angespannt werden, die Situation in der nächsten Saison mit den vier Absteigern. Vielleicht kann da jemand von profitieren und anderen Schnüppchen schlagen?
Ich glaube, eine Mannschaft, die bestens strukturiert ist oder war, vielleicht das modernste und schönste Stadion der Liga hat, das beste Jugendzentrum, weil dort Spieler wie Kaim Benzema, Atem Ben Affar, ausgebildet wurden. Ich rede natürlich von Oland Biklion. Der kommt in der Saison nicht im Europa-Bukal dabei, erneut. Nicht in der Champions League vorliegen, das war das Hauptziel. Und wenn sich die Millionäre, und das hat der Präsident Jean-Michel Olaß erwähnt, man wird schon gewisse Mittel haben, weil man hat jetzt neue Aktionäre in dem Verein, sodass man sich trotzdem klug verstärken kann und punktuell. Aber dass man dann keine Spiele unter der Woche hat, kann schon zum Vorteil werden. Ich will mal einen vernünftigen Trainer endlich mal erholen wieder und eine spartkräftige Mannschaft aufbauen und die Sorgenkinder in dem jetzigen Kader verkaufen können und loshaben können, damit wieder bessere Stimmung herrscht, also wenn dann, oder ein bisschen jung, aber das Schwarzburg zum Beispiel erneut überrascht, wird schon schwer. Die einzige Chance ist, dass der Julian Stefan bleibt, aber wie gesagt, er ist von Jung, Heiß und Worben und ich denke, auf Rhein ist wieder Verlass, weil es eine Mannschaft, die auf Kontinuität setzt und in der Lage ist, auch wieder für Überraschung zu sorgen, er sein wird.
Na dann werden wir doch mal gucken. Und dann die Abschlussfrage, welche Anekdoten gibt es denn aus dieser Ligue 1 Saison, wo du sagst, wenn ich dich in fünf Jahren anspreche, weißt du noch, damals in der Saison, in der MAP seinen Vertrag unterschrieben hat und PSG quasi zum Kylian Mbappé-Filialclub wurde, an was wirst du dich denn darüber hinaus noch erinnern, an dieser Ligue 1 Saison?
Ja, dass es halt viele verrückte Spiele gab, aber natürlich bleibt in Erinnerung in der Hinrunde diese zu oft gesehenen Spielerbrüchen in Nizza, in Lyon, in Angers gegen Marseille. Das war schon sehr traurig, weil man hatte die Pandemie, es war so oft oder monatelang Spiele unter Aufschluss der Öffentlichkeit, Geisterspiele, wie man so schön sagt, und danach wieder Spiele um Zuschauer aus disziplinarischen Gründen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir solche Szenen nicht mehr sehen werden. Das halte ich für schwierig, weil Fankai ist immer ein heißes Pflaster im Punkt der Fußball, und das hat mich schon traurig gemacht, in der Hinrunde immer wieder Spiele kommentieren zu dürfen, wo nach drei Minuten nichts mehr los war, weil die Spieler alle in der Kabine waren, weil das Spiel abgebrochen wurde und nicht mehr angepfiffen. Und die Verantwortlichen der Liga nicht in der Lage waren, das Spiel erst nach zwei Stunden abzubrechen und nicht schnell Konsequenzen zu treffen. Und ich hoffe, das kommt nicht mehr wieder vor, aber da habe ich leider meine Bedenken. Positiv betrachtet muss man fast schon MBP erwähnen. Man dachte, vor allem nach dem Außenreal, er kann nur noch dorthin wechseln. Aber ich denke persönlich, warum er verlängert hat, ich glaube, er kann sich, die PSG-Fans können sich bei Karim Benzema belangen. Hätte dieser positiv verrückte Stürmer von Real nicht dermaßen oft getroffen in den letzten Wochen, wäre natürlich Real nicht im Finale. Und dann hat MBP jetzt gecheckt, festgestellt, warum soll ich dorthin wechseln, gewinnt eh alles ohne mich. Und wenn ich in Paris bleibe und gewinne dort zum ersten Mal die Champions League in der Vereinsgeschichte, dann werde ich ein richtiger Held. Und das glaube ich in seinen Augen, auch in seinem Kopf. Der Kilian ist auch ein sehr wichtiges Argument.
Spannend. Nimmt er den steinigen Weg? Da bin ich ja sehr gespannt, wie der verlaufen wird. Alexi, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Danke nicht nur jetzt für diese Zusammenfassung, sondern auch für all deine Unterstützung während dieser Saison. Na ja, Urlaub mehr oder weniger. Und ebenfalls natürlich danke an David Frangier, der Paul Lévoix, dem wir ja hier auch häufiger zur Ligue 1 gehört haben. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Abonniert gerne auch die Schlusskonferenz. Da kommt in Kürze der Rasenfunk Royale raus. Der ausführliche Rutschblick auf die Männer Bundesliga mit je einem Gast pro Verein plus noch einzelnen Segmenten zu Schiedsrichtern, Torhütern, Taktik und den Rasenfunk erscheint am Mittwoch und unterstützt gerne den Rasenfunk finanziell. Wir sind werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Allein eure freiwilligen Zahlungen halten dieses Projekt hier am Laufen. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. In diesem Sinne habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht es gut, bis bald, bleibt gesund, ciao.